make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so in the last video we brought in
what was essentially Excalibur alpha
flight and blue Marvel as new faces
right some fresh faces and we did some
things like we talked about Black
Panther - that we would basically do do
more in the sense that Black Panther
would essentially be injured over the
course of Doctor Doom invading Latveria
or at least setting up a coup d'etat and
stealing all of its vibranium and that
he would pass the mantle of Black
Panther to his sister Shuri just like he
did in the comics these are the kind of
things that we would cover here right
and so in this video we are going to
bring back a few familiar faces and
we're also going to bring in some
totally new faces right and so what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna pick
up with ant-man 3 now the important
thing to understand as ant-man 3 is
actually coming out relatively soon
technically as part of phase 5 so it's
gonna be with be out within the next you
know two to three years I think so it'll
be out long before we get to this part
in the movie line up but we're actually
gonna piggyback off of it and the reason
why is because we'd have to assume that
in ant-man 3 Cassie laying would have in
some former fashion a superhero esque
role in relation to her father now it
could also be one of these things where
her dad's like don't do superhero stuff
like literally half the universe got
wiped out like you don't like no no no
you don't do superhero antics you stay
home and and you you study and you you
take your classes and and that's it
that's all you do that could very well
be to be an approach that he takes I
think that's the most practical approach
because I think that for a lot of young
people they could find that relatable
that parents are kind of imposing rules
and boundaries and different things like
that and I think it would go a long way
to making the kit the character of
Cassie Lang very relatable in the eyes
of a lot of teenagers and young people
who would go to see these films but the
reason why I think that's even more
important is the film that we follow up
in terms of really I guess officially
this first portion of the films that
we're making what we do here is we kick
things off with Nova and Nova is going
to be from from my perspective it's
gonna be Sam Alexander I know a lot of
old school fans really want to see
Richard Ryder but as most people will
tell you anybody who's been reading
Richard Ryder for a long enough time
will tell you his character pretty much
sucked until annihilation and that's
really just the way it is right there
was really nothing interesting about
Richard writer until annihilation where
Sam Alexander is young and vibrant and
still relatively fresh more so than that
I think his story fits in better with
the events of Avengers in game because
it makes things more personal and the
comics Sam Alexander's father had
basically gone missing and the whole
idea was for Sam Alexander to use his
father's Nova technology in order to
locate him right to find out what it was
that had happened to
what we do here is we basically save the
Sam Alexander or at least that that
Peter quill we can kind of tie this into
guardians of the galaxy but we could say
Peter quill was not the first or only
earthling abducted from Earth right that
Sam Alexander's father was actually part
of the Nova Corps operating on Xandar
that he would come back every so often
where he had just left and we never
really found out why right thats a
knowledge editor thought he'd been
abandoned or something along those lines
whatever that case is that after the
events of Avengers infinity war when
Thanos had invaded Xander and taken the
Power Stone but stem Alexander's father
was one of the people who died and so as
a result of that his father's helmet
basically travels back to earth and then
tell Sam Alexander you are now your
father's replacement in the Nova Corps
right and so Sam Alexander literally has
to fly by the seat of his pants and
learn how to use his powers right which
is a pretty fun and a pretty cool
adventure to follow up with that's one
of the cool things about this is people
love the idea of origin stories but they
also love watching a character learn how
to use their powers it's one of the
things we love the most about high in
man right Tony Stark learning how to use
his abilities and then flying himself
into the ceiling right like those are
things that were really fun and really
enjoyable those popular themes can
continue on with the character of Sam
Alexander and so this is particularly
important because what it does is it
leads into our next movie The Young
Avengers and the Young Avengers here I
think would be a great way to sort of
capitalize on the popularity of Sam
Alexander right this idea of a young
vibrant superhero who's now being
recruited into a team more so than that
the Young Avengers kind of gives us this
sort of staging ground that's kind of
proving ground right almost like the
initiative those guys you don't know
what that is the initiative was
basically what happened in Marvel Comics
after the Civil War event was won by
Iron Man and Reed Richards and all those
guys they basically had what was called
a 50-state initiative where there would
be registered superheroes in all 50
states and they would be designated for
the purpose of protecting that state
unless the threat in that state was so
big that it required more avengers from
other states to be called in and so
because of that they basically ended up
having this process where they would
they would essentially go through and
teach heroes how to become heroes they
would go through a whole training
process which a reality wasn't the worst
thing ever but you know like Captain
America freedom you know all that kind
of stuff and so ultimately the the whole
process ended up going away but that's
more or less what you do here you treat
the Young Avengers as not really young
people who are sanctioned by the
Avengers but you blend it with the
comics and the sense that in the comic
books the Young Avengers were a a group
of teenage kids who basically took up
the mantle of more or less being
Avengers being you know
avenging Avenger kids in the aftermath
of Avengers disassembled when the
Avengers team was disbanded and the
launch of new Avengers when the team was
reformed they were just kind of there in
the middle but and they fought some
pretty heavy hitters right they beat out
like King the Conqueror who's a pretty
powerful time-traveling guy there were
some some cool moments there right but
they weren't officially sanctioned and
in fact when the Avengers reformed one
of the first acts what's the basically
chastise the New Avengers or the Young
Avengers and to say you're too young for
this right you know but they ended up
keeping on keeping on and and they
proved to be exceedingly popular among
young leaders in Marvel Comics it's a
great way to segue and to really sort of
tap in to a lot of the young viewers in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so the
younger vision I think would be a great
way to go right we kind of keep that
legacy of the Avengers roster going
right to the team would consist of
Cassie Lange Kate Bishop Thomas and
Billy the children of Scarlet Witch and
then of course Sam Alexander is Nova
which is a pretty solid lineup for that
for that team I think right and so
following that what we do is we shift
over to our next film which is the
winter guard and this film much like
Alpha Flight is going to have more or
less a teaser for the x-men and this
comes in the form of a guy none other
than Peter
Rasputin you may also know him as
Colossus and the way this plays out is
that in the comics the winter guard was
Russia's answer to the Avengers team
right and the idea was that because it
really took place here in the Cold War
and the United States had an Avengers
team Russia wanted to have one of their
own right the superhero race right like
before yeeah the nuclear arms race you
had the superhero race going on as well
right and so would that be in the case
unlike the Avengers team in the United
States that was a volunteer-based team
so long as they accepted you into their
ranks and was financed by Tony Stark
what you had with the winner guard is
the Russian government traveled around
their country and then conscripted
people into the winter guard right like
if they got a hold of you you had to
join like there was no way to get out of
it I mean I guess you could escape
Russia right but there was no way to you
couldn't say no like that wasn't really
an option and so what had happened is
that through a combination of giant-size
x-men number one bile in wine and and
Chris Claremont the Colossus origin
story the the one shot we ended up
learning that Colossus was supposed to
be conscripted into the winter guard but
Charles Xavier arrived there just in the
nick of time to basically save Colossus
and an intern was recruited into his
x-men team in order to rescue the
original x-men team you do something
similar to that what you basically say
here is that you you don't really have a
great big huge moment you have the
winter guard doing the winter guard
thing whatever it is but in the early
recruiting phases somebody walks into a
room they talked
somebody else or you over here a couple
of guys smoking cigarettes drinking
coffee and and it's kinda like okay you
know do we have any light here we have
any news about that Rasputin guy because
he seemed like a really good asset for
the Winter Garden the responses no like
some bald guy came out of nowhere and
just whisked him away we know we have no
idea what's going on but it's just a
referenced right to Colossus being
rescued by Charles Xavier of the x-men
and being brought to the United States
to find on the x-men team right so it's
a small little easter egg a small little
moment but a great way to kind of
continue that foundation like we did
with Alpha Flight in Wolverine it's a
great way to build that foundation and
to slowly introduce the x-men into the
MCU and so what we do here with our
final film in this this video and with
this section of the whole thing we bring
back to people who are left over from
the original Avengers team and they
combine them with the Young Avengers and
then we call this team the New Avengers
right so that's really how we kind of
end this right now this roster would
consist of Sam Wilson Captain America
Lila Barton in place of Kate Bishop
right because we could largely assume
that Lila Barton is gonna be the one
who's gonna be the new Hawkeye as
opposed to Kate Bishop we also have
spider-man we have Black Panther we have
Nova we have blue Marvel and we have
Cassie Lang it's a great way to kind of
combine these new faces along with these
older faces and continue this tradition
I feel like if we launch the New
Avengers and it was just a wholly new
face a wholly new team with no ties to
the original team I feel like people
don't reject that because I feel like
people would look at that and they would
see that it's too far removed from the
original Avengers team people would be
like no we want to see some of these
familiar faces right like even if you're
working them out we want to see that
this somehow ties into the the last 10
years and to be able to say that like
Sam Wilson in these guys bring a lot of
experience to the table that other
people just don't have right that the
Sam Wilson and spider-man and black
panther can say okay look we were there
during the whole like invasion of Earth
by Thanos and all that kind of stuff we
were fighting there we saw these events
unfold all that kind of stuff we bring a
kind of experience to the table that you
just can't buy and they can pass that on
to the new generation now one person
that I do want to point your attention
to here is Black Panther truthfully
speaking Black Panther would normally be
the king of Wakanda but in the last
video that we did we basically said that
Black Panther 2 would be do more and
what that would do is it would basically
have Doctor Doom invade Wakanda or at
least set up a coup d'etat and Wakanda
that would lead to black panther being
ousted and then during the process he
would be injured meaning he would pass
the mantle to his sister Cherie and
black panther himself would be left
powerless and the funny thing is we
can't leave that for long and Momma
comics didn't either right
only after the events of doom work
Jonathan Hickman took over Fantastic
Four and one of the first things he did
is he had or not really even the first
thing in I think it might have been
towards the end but he ended up having
read Richards of the Fantastic Four
meeting with Black Panther and they both
went down to the City of the Dead and
they spoke with bass the Panther God and
the Charlie basically said I'm not black
panther anymore you've given that power
to my sister's she should be the one to
maintain that power but I need some kind
of new ability I need some new role and
so bast made Black Panther the king of
the Dead which allowed him to
communicate with his ancestors and even
control the dead at any point in time
now the only time we really saw him
control the dead was during Secret Wars
2015 where he controlled the Marvel
Zombies but it allows him to basically
maintain his power set as we
traditionally see him as white panther
super strength super speed enhanced
agility different things like that which
means he can go on and still become a
pretty formidable member and and for the
most part maintain his same role within
the Avengers team now
this combined with the intelligence that
he has as well as the super high
intelligence of blue Marvel more than
makes up for the lack of Iron Man of
course Cassie Lang also brings in
technology in terms of her use of Pym
technology which by this point in the
the movie landscape will have been
sanctioned by Scott Lang he basically
would have would have come to accept it
and then become okay with it but these
are some cool things I think these are
this is a pretty solid lineup in terms
of a new Avengers team but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you